Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
(Musique de boîte de nuit)
(Bruit de porte)
(Pas sur le gravier)
(portière de voiture)
(démarrage de voiture)
(conduite)
(accident)
(Sirène d’ambulance)
(battement de cœur régulier)
(battement qui ralentit)
(dernier battement de cœur)
Ça pourrait être nous.
Un de nos proches.
Nous pourrions aussi être celle ou celui
qui va lui sauver la vie.
Qui n’a jamais rêvé
de le faire, sincèrement ?
Sauver des vies ?
Être un héros ?
Nous ne sommes pas tous secouristes,
médecins ou pompiers.
Mais nous pouvons tous sauver des vies
avec un geste simple :
le don du sang.
Et il n'est pas nécessaire
de donner pour sauver.
Il suffit parfois d'en parler.
Chaque année dans le monde,
plus de 100 millions de poches
sont prélevées
pour être transfusées aux personnes
qui en ont besoin.
Ces personnes,
ce sont des malades de tous âges,
du bébé qui naît avec l’incapacité
de produire des globules efficaces
jusqu’à la personne âgée,
dont on va prolonger la vie
de quelques semaines,
quelques mois,
peut être même quelques années.
Et puis, il y a tout un tas de maladies,
de pathologies qu'on va pouvoir soulager
grâce aux transfusions.
Il y a aussi les femmes dont
l’accouchement est hémorragique.
Avant les transfusions,
c’est une sur deux qui mourait
à la naissance de son enfant.
Et puis, il y a les victimes d’accidents,
d’agressions.
Nous pouvons tous, à un moment
de notre vie, avoir besoin de sang.
Et pour en recevoir,
il faut que des gens en aient donné.
Y a-t-il ici ce soir des personnes
qui ont déjà donné leur sang ?
Mm.
OK.
Et y a-t-il des personnes qui
ne se sont jamais présentées
sur un lieu de collecte ?
Alors, soyez pas timides,
normalement, vous êtes majoritaires.
(rires)
Mm.
Eh bien, t’as fait quoi du coup ?
Oh, laisse moi deviner,
tu es allé sur un lieu de collecte
et tu as fait un malaise
en voyant l’aiguille.
(rires)
Ça arrive et c'est pas grave.
D’ailleurs, il y a plein de raisons
pour lesquelles on peut
ne pas pouvoir donner son sang.
Parce que pour donner,
il ne suffit pas de vouloir.
Il faut aussi pouvoir.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’éligibilité.
Et selon certaines études,
seul 40% de la population
est éligible au don du sang.
Oui, moins d’une personne sur deux.
Ça paraît peu.
Mais ce qui paraît encore moins,
c’est que sur ces 40%,
il n’y a qu’une personne sur 10
qui va franchir le pas.
Et au final,
c’est seulement 4%
de la population qui donne.
Ça, c'est vraiment peu.
Comment est-ce que ça se fait ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait qu’on donne ou pas ?
Alors pour moi, c’est facile,
mais déjà parce que je travaille là-bas.
Ensuite, parce que je viens
d’une grande famille de donneurs.
Chez nous, tout le monde donne.
Mes parents, mes frères et sœurs,
et avant nous, nos grands-parents
déjà donnaient leur sang.
Le plus fort,
ou le plus fou, peut être,
c’est mon grand-père maternel.
Imaginez un peu.
Oui, c'était il y a longtemps,
dans les années 60.
(rires)
En plein désert,
en mission militaire.
Voilà.
Un camarade a besoin d’une transfusion.
Ils sont compatibles.
Et qu’est-ce qui va se passer ?
Ben oui, il va lui donner son sang,
lui sauver la vie,
en direct.
Et puis, quand je dis en direct, c'est pas
une image, une aiguille dans un bras,
une aiguille dans l'autre et c'est parti.
Impressionnant, non ?
Alors, je vous rassure tout de suite,
c’est pas du tout comme ça
que ça se passe aujourd’hui.
Les techniques ont beaucoup évolué.
Aujourd’hui, pour donner son sang,
on se présente sur un lieu de collecte.
On remplit un questionnaire.
Et puis, on va rencontrer une personne
qui détermine
si oui ou non on peut donner.
Vous vous rappelez,
40% seulement de la population
est éligible.
Ça, c'est mon travail.
Je vais donc évaluer différents critères.
Déjà , il y a l’âge.
Avant 18 ans,
on est trop jeune,
et après 70 ans,
on est trop vieux.
(rires)
Et puis, il y a l'état de santé
de la personne qui donne.
Il faut être suffisamment
en forme pour ça.
Certaines maladies cardiaques,
neurologiques, hématologiques
(rires)
ne permettent pas le don du sang.
Dans ces cas-là , il vaut mieux prendre
un peu de repos parce qu’on veut aussi
protéger la personne qui donne.
Et puis, bien sûr, il y a
la personne qui reçoit.
On ne veut pas lui faire courir de risque.
Certains voyages, tatouages,
changements de partenaire sexuel,
(rires)
entraîneront une contre indication
de quatre mois.
Mais si tous ces critères sont respectés,
(vous trouverez la liste en ligne,
je vous la fais pas en entier)
c’est parti pour le don.
Simple.
Rapide.
Le prélèvement dure seulement 10 minutes.
Pile le temps de regarder
une conférence TEDx.
Après ça, pour vous, c'est bon,
vous avez fait votre part.
Vous pouvez passer en zone de collation,
vous reposer, manger un morceau,
et bien vous hydrater.
Merci.
Mais la poche, elle, ne s’arrête pas là .
Après avoir été prélevée,
elle va être transportée au laboratoire
pour être techniqué.
D'un côté , votre sang va être analysé .
De quel groupe sanguin êtes-vous ?
Combien de globules contenait
votre sang ce jour-là ?
Et surtout,
y avait-il des microbes ?
Si oui,
votre poche va être écartée,
puis détruite.
On ne veut pas faire courir de risque
à la personne qui reçoit.
Ça, c’est ce qu’on appelle
la qualification biologique du don.
La poche pendant ce temps,
va passer en préparation.
Oui, parce que nous, ce qu’on donne
en dix minutes, c’est du sang total.
Mais il n'est pas transfusé tel quel.
Il va être séparé
en ses  différents composants
pour être distribué selon les besoins.
Le sang, c’est
des globules rouges, des plaquettes,
des globules blancs, et du plasma
pour transporter tout ça.
Les globules rouges,
ils transportent l’oxygène
dans l’organisme,
c’est vital.
C’est eux que vous voyez dans les poches
rouges qu’on transfuse à l’hôpital.
(rires)
Les plaquettes,
elles servent à boucher les trous
lorsqu’on se blesse, qu’on saigne.
Elles viennent arrêter l'hémorragie.
Et les globules blancs,
ce sont les gardiens de l’organisme
propres à chacun.
Ils sont uniques, ils nous protègent,
mais on ne peut pas les transfuser.
Le plasma, c'est le liquide
qui transporte tout ça.
Il fait le lien
entre les différents organes.
Bon, ce n’est pas ce qu’il y a
de plus facile à mimer,
mais c’est très facile à reconstituer.
Après un don de sang.
(applaudissements)
Après un don de sang,
si on est en bonne santé,
on s’hydrate bien
et on reconstitue dans la journée
le liquide qui nous a été prélevé.
Pour les globules blancs
et les plaquettes, c’est pareil,
en quelques jours, on les refait.
Les globules rouges, par contre,
c’est un peu plus long.
Dans notre corps,
leur durée de vie est de 21 jours,
donc en général, il faut
trois semaines pour les reconstituer,
jusqu’à un mois.
C’est pour ça qu’il y a un délai
de 2 mois entre deux dons de sang
pour que notre corps puisse se reposer
et refaire ses réserves.
Mais quand on les prélève,
ces globules rouges, on les met au frais
dans une solution de conservation.
Ils peuvent alors tenir 42 jours.
Ça parait beaucoup, non ?
Mais vous vous rappelez ?
100 millions de poches chaque année.
Plus de 2 millions par semaine.
C’est tous les jours qu’on a besoin
de sang, toute l’année,
pas seulement quand on y pense
une fois de temps en temps.
Pas seulement quand il y a
des appels urgents aux dons.
Parce que, qu’est-ce qu’il se passe
si jamais on manque de sang ?
Si jamais on n’a pas assez de sang,
si jamais on n’a pas de poche
du groupe suffisant,
on va se retrouver avec une personne
qu’on pourrait sauver et qui va
mourir faute d’avoir été transfusée.
Si on n’a pas assez de sang en stock,
on va se retrouver à devoir sélectionner
à qui on va transfuser
le peu de poches dont on dispose.
On a besoin de vous tout le temps.
Les personnes qui sont éligibles,
si chacun d’entre vous, si chacun d’entre
nous donne son sang deux fois par an,
on n’aura plus jamais besoin
de lancer des appels aux dons.
Et pour toutes les personnes
qui ne peuvent pas
ou ne veulent pas donner,
il n’y a aucun problème pour ça.
Vous pouvez aussi faire votre part.
Vous aussi vous pouvez aider.
Vous aussi, vous pouvez contribuer
à sauver des vies.
Comment ?
En en parlant, en partageant des articles,
en accompagnant des amis, des collègues,
ou même en rejoignant une association
de promotion du don du sang,
pour qu’on ait toujours en stock
des poches préparées,
qualifiées, sécurisées,
prêtes à être transfusées
aux personnes qui en ont besoin.
Ces personnes, c’est peut-être
des inconnus,
mais ça peut aussi être des proches.
Ou bien nous ?
Merci.
(applaudissements)
Merci